en fait et ça c'est déjà fait
les paellas quand
senti en mesure
des sites se tient pour mortes de
choquant à coude
alors la tendance du normandie alors
novembre du plaisir risques posés
reniant
l'annoncé
donc a déjà ses produits sont déjà en
profiter depuis longtemps qu est
maintenant on va compléter ce avec des
produits made in france
mais d'énormes risques et se poursuit
tout à fait non pour tout bon
notre client qu'il est avec l'ancien
commercial va distribuer la boîte aux
mini mini one de 5 ans
dakar
car on
et on a vu ça s'arrête a du chien
mais le char c'est plus simple de garder
chez eux mais on préfère le chien j'ai
la phobie de chats je peux mais j'aime
beaucoup le chien mais dans le ja pas
j'ai beaucoup
moi je suis pas comme un avion